قال المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كريم خان انه من الممكن محاكمه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في وقت ما
لانه لا احد فوق المحاسبه ممن يرتكبون
اعمال اباده جماعيه او جرائم ضد الانسانيه
او جرائم حرب وكانت عواصم غربيه قد رحبت
باصدار المحكمه مذكرتي توقيف ضد بوتين في
منطقه موسكو المحكمه والقرار الصادر عنها
بشده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف بدت ردود الفعل
المختلفه من مذكرتي الاعتقال اللتين
اصدرتهما المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بحق
بوتين وما هي خيارات روسيا ازاءات تلك
الخطوه ما تاثير الفعل والمباشر المرتقب
لهذه الخطوه على المواجهه القائمه بين
موسكو والعواصم الغربيه على ضوء المسارات
التي تنتظر اجراءات العداله الدوليه بحق
الرئيس الروسي واي جدوى لها قياسا لمذكرات
اعتقال سابقه بحق الزعماء اي فرص للجهود
الراميه لابهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا عبر
تسويه سياسيه في الوقت الذي يوجد فيه مسار
قانوني دولي يلوح بمحاسبه كل من تثبت بحقه
جرائم تتقاضاف الحرب في اوكرانيا
المسؤوليه عن ارتكابها
[موسيقى]
ساحه جديده اضيفت الى مربعات الصراع بين
روسيا ودول الغربيه تتمثل هذه المره في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه من هناك صدرت
مذكره اعتقال بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين على خلفيه اتهامه بالضلوع في جرائم
حرب واخرى ضد الانسانيه ارتكبت تحت امرته
في اوكرانيا صب القرار مزيدا من الزيت على
نيران تتصاعد والسنتها بين موسكو والعواصم
الغربيه التي رحبت بالقرار الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن قال ان مذكره الاعتقال
الصادره عن الجنائيه الدوليه بحق بوتين
مبرره فهو قد ارتكب بوضوح جرائم حرب في
نفس الاتجاه اكد مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه
والامن بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل ان
قرار الجنائيه الدوليه مجرد بدايه لمحاسبه
روسيا على جرائمها الرد الروسي جاء لاذعا
من عده مستويات رسميه فقد وصف المتحدث
باسم الكريم
القراره بالمستفز وغير المقبول مشددا على
ان من صدر عن الجنائيه الدوليه لا قيمه له
ولا اهميه له على الاطلاق المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه قالت ان
الغاء جميع العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا
وسحب جميع الدعاوى القضائيه غير القانونيه
ضدها في المحاكم الدوليه يجب ان يكون جزءا
لا يتجزا من التسويه بشان اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
بمناقصه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو السفير
اندريه بك لانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه
الدبلوماسيين الروس ومن بيروت ديال داليا
شحاده المحاميه السابقه في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ومن واشنطن السفير
ويليام كورت نيم مساعد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق لشؤون روسيا واوكرانيا ابدا معك
سيد
اندريه الجانب الروسي قال ان هذه المذكره
او مذكرتي التوقيف لا قيمه لهما وانه ليس
جزءا من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولكن
الا تؤدي هذه القرارات الى شل حركه بوتين
والتقليل من قدرته وعزلته دوليا
في حقيقه الامر نعم اعتقد
انها ستكون جوله جديده من زياده سوء
العلاقات بين روسيا والغرب في موسكو
يقولون انه بالاضافه الى
اضغوطات الاقتصاديه والماليه
والمظاهر العقوبات الاخرى
لدينا امكانيه الحرب القضائيه على السلطه
في روسيا وبالتاكيد فان اطراف الحرب
استحباب
بحصانه بعدما سيحدث في حقيقه الامر لقد
توقعنا مثل هذا التطور
لاننا في موسكو معظم المراقبين يتحدثون لا
يتحدثون عن الفحوى القرار لكن يتحدثون عن
السياسه السياسه التي قد تكون ربما اكثر
نفعا لروسيا مقارنه بالدول الاوروبيه هذا
هو فحوى النقاش ما الذي يجب ان نقوم به من
اجل ايقاف مثل هذه النشاطات لماذا الغرب
والولايات المتحده
خسروا اي شعورا
بالخطر فيما يتعلق
عندما يتعلق الامر بموسكو هذا الامر لم
يحدث في السابق طيب سيد اندريه رحبت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بهذا القرار
هل هي حفاوه برمزيه القرار ام انها تامل
الى ان يؤدي بمفاعيل حقيقيه على الارض
اعتقد
ان اصدقائنا الامريكيين قاموا بالتنظيم
والعمل لهذا العمل المسرحي فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في اوكرانيا الامر لن يكن له تاثير
فوري على المعارك لكن هذا الامر يعني ان
احتماليه
التسويه السياسيه السلميه اصبحت ابعد
واصعب ولربما
اصبحت حظوظها صفرا بالتالي الحرب ستستمر
وهذه هي نتيجه طبيعيه لما حدث طيب سيد
ويليام اذا لمفاعيل حسب ما يقول الجانب
الروسي لهذا
القرار بالتالي لماذا رحبت فيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا كان سيعقد التسويه
السياسيه كما يقول السيد اندريه
اعتقد ان
القرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ستجعل من
قرار التسويه السياسيه امرا صعبا
اعتقد ان هنالك جرائم حرب خطيره وجرائم
مثلا اعمال العنف في برجر ايضا سيتم
اعتبارها ايضا
اعمال
جرائم حرب هذا هذه هذا القرار
بسمعه بوتين
وقد هذا يساهم ايضا بادراك روسيا بان
العدوان على اوكرانيا يكلف روسيا الكثير
وقد ربما يدفع روسيا لاتخاذ قرار منطقي
للانسحاب من اوكرانيا سيد ويليام ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مساله
سابقه قامت بفرض عقوبات على المدعيه
العامه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الا ترى
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
تعاطيها مع هذه المحكمه بالاساس تكيلو
بمكيالين
الولايات المتحده هي ليست عضوا في ميثاق
الامم المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وكذلك
روسيا الولايات المتحده لديها اسباب اخرى
لعدم تكون عضوا وموقعا في
قانون روما الاساسي المكون للمحكمه لكن
هنالك جرائم حرب حصلت وتم اختطاف اطفال
ايضا هناك الى روسيا انطلاقا من هنا توجه
اليك
سيدتيالا ما قيمه القرار الصادر عن محكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
القرار له من دون شك قيمه قانونيه حتى ولو
لم يتم تنفيذه في القريب العاجل بالضروره
وذلك لان القرارات الصادره عن المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بما في ذلك مذكرات
التوقيف لا تسقط بمرور الزمن ولا بالتقادم
وشاهدنا في على المستوى الجنائي الدولي
بما في ذلك امام الجنائيه الدوليه مسؤولين
وزعماء ورؤساء السابقين تم التنفيذ مذكرات
التوقيف بحقهم ولو بعد سنوات بعدما خسروا
الحصانه او القوه السياسيه داخل بلاد التي
كانوا يتمتعون بها ولعلها هذه الملاحقات
ايضا اثرت عليها ايضا لهذه نحن نتحدث عن
دوله عظمى هذه المره زعيم دوله عظمى تمتلك
حق النقد الفيتو داخل الامم المتحده
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مستقله تماما عن
الامم المتحده وقرارات القضاه اتخذ على
مستوى الدوائر القضائيه تمت حاله وحيده
يمكن لها تاخير اجراءات المحكمه الدوليه
على المستوى القضائي وهو ان يتفق مجلس
الامن
باجماع حمله الفيتو باكثريه اعضائه غير
الدائمين على ارجاء اجراءات القضائيه في
ملف الاثنى عشر شهرا طالما ان هذا الامر
هو في صالح السلم والامن الدوليين ولم
يحصل ذلك في تاريخ المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه حتى اليوم ايضا تمت قوه
قانونيه ولكن سياسيه وهي
عدم قدره بوتين على زياره نحو ثلثي
والالعالم وهي الدول الاعضاء في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه 123 دوله وقد شهدنا
حالات سابقه
ضيقت فيها الحركه الدبلوماسيه وبالتالي
الوظائف السياسيه التي يقوم بها رئيس
البلاد واثرت ايضا على مكانته اخوته
السياسيه داخل بلاده طيب كثير من النقاط
لابد من التوقف عندها سيده ديالها ولكن
دعيني اسمع من السيد اندريه سيد اندريه
يعني في ظل ما قالته السيده ديالا بان
ما تقوم به المحكمه الدوليه والقرارات
الصادره عنها لا تسقط بالتقادم بالتالي
كيف يمكن ان ترد روسيا على قرارات
الجنائيه الدوليه وعلى الترحيب بهذه
القرارات
انا لست متاكدا
من ان قيادتنا السياسيه
ينظرون الى هذا الامر بجديه كبيره لانه
حتى قبل ذلك كان هنالك قبل اتخاذ القرار
كان الوضع
حيث ان
الوضع
الحالي مع الغرب كان ربما هنالك منع
لزياره الدول الغربيه في فرنسا وانجلترا
والولايات المتحده وكان هنالك ايقاف
الزيارات السياحيه مثلا لتلك البلدان فيما
يتعلق ببقيه دول العالم فان الدول التي
تهمنا لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر هذا القرار
سيؤثر على تلك الدول بالتاكيد سيكون هنالك
دراسه للوضع بشكل مستفيد لكن علينا ان
نتذكر
يعني تركز على امكانيه الزيارات وهنا
يستطيع الرئيس بوتين ان لا يقوم بها ولكن
في امثله سابقه عندما تغير
تغير نظام الحكم في بلد ما او عندما لم
يعد الرئيس رئيسا في بلد ما لم يمنع ذلك
من اتى بعده بان يقدمه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه هل تاخذون ذلك بعين
الاعتبار
اعتقد ان المشكله هو من هو الرئيس ومن هو
الرئيس الفعلي هذا هو حق الشعب في تقرير
هذا الامر اما فيما يتعلق بالدول
والمنظمات الاخرى هم باستطاعتهم ان يكون
لهم وجهات نظر مختلفه نحن لا يمكننا ان
نتدخل في هذه الامور الامر يعتمد على
الموقف لكن استطيع ان اؤكد لك اننا لا
ننظر الى هذا الامر بجديه لان الحرب قد
بدات طيب باختصار لو سمحت لي يعني احدى
الردود جاءت من نائب رئيس مجلس الاتحاد
الروسي ولوح بفرض عقوبات على اعضاء هذه
المحكمه هل هذه امكانيه وارده بتقديرك
المحاولات
لربما فرضي عقوبات قد تكون بطريقه محتمله
نحن نقوم بتجاهل هذه السلطه القانونيه
تجاهلناها منذ سنوات سنتجاهل كل الاجراءات
التي تلوح بها فيما يتعلق
بسلوك خلال الاوقات الحاليه نحن ربما
سندرس هذا الامر لكن لا اعتقد انه سيكون
انه له تاثير تراجيدي على بلدنا نحن بلد
قوي ونحن نمتلك كل شيء
لدينا التسلح ولدينا
[موسيقى]
الحبوب ولدينا
الغاز والنفط بالتالي نحن لا نعتمد على
الغرب او على اي قرارين يتخذه الغرب طيب
سيد ويليام كيف ستستفيد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتستغل هذا القرار سياسيا على
اقل تقدير في الصراع الدائر في الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هذا القرار سوف يدعم
التوافقات والوحده بين الدول الغربيه من
اجل مساعدتي اوكرانيا لصد العدواني الروسي
سوف يدعم الموقف الموحد للغرب والعقوبات
التي يفرضها على روسيا بالتالي التاثير قد
يكون كبيرا
بالتاكيد فان الرئيس ولم يسافر الى الغرب
لكنه اذا ما حاول ان يسافر الى اجزاء اخرى
في العالم هذا القرار قد يعيقوا سفره طيب
قد يعيق سفره ولكن ما مدى واقعيه اي يسافر
الرئيس بوتين الى هذه الدول جنوب افريقيا
استقبلت البشير سابقا للرئيس السوداني
السابق ولم يسلم حتى لمحكمه الجناء
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه سيد ويليام
تاثير هذا القرار على اي تسويه سياسيه ان
اطلت براسها لا يمكن الجلوس مع الرئيس
بوتين
هنالك تقليد
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الى حد الان لم
يصدر فيها اي قرار كيف يمكن ان نقرا ذلك
من الناحيه هل هو سياسي هل قرار سياسي ام
قانوني
ابدا بالشكل الاول وهو زياره البشير حين
صدرت مذكرات التوقيف بجرائم عديده ومنها
الاباده الجماعيه بحقل البشير منذ العام
اثرت هذه القرارات وقرارات اخرى في ملفات
اخرى على الاتحاد الدول الافريقيه لانها
رات ان المحكمه الجنائيه في حينه في العام
2009 لم تكن قد فتحت تحقيقات بعد سوى في
ملفات في الدول الافريقيه ورات في ذلك
نوعا من عدم التوازن وهذا الامر تغير وهنا
واليوم يوجد اكثر من اربعه عشر حاله في
دول مختلفه من خارج افريقيا كذلك وفي
اوروبا وفلسطين المحتله وفي اوكرانيا
وايضا في امريكا اللاتينيه ولكن البشير لم
يتمكن من زياره عدد من الدول وحتى حين زار
دوله كينيا صدرت بحقه مذكره توقيفه وطنيه
بتحرك من المجتمع الحقيقي فيه وحتى حين
كان في جنوب افريقيا حصلت بلبله في
المجتمع الحقوقي اضطرت الى تقصير زيارته
وكل ذلك اثر عليه بشكل سياسي اهرجه وضيق
حركته السياسيه وفعليا عدم قدره الاشخاص
المطلوبين من السياسيين بارزين على السفر
الى هذه الدول هي نوع من السجن الكبير لهم
بعيدا عن الاماكن التي كانوا هم يقومون
فيها بوظائفهم الدبلوماسيه فيما يتعلق
بالشق الثاني من سؤالك في سرعه اجراء هذا
اصدار هذا القرار
التحقيقات في هذا الملف بدات منذ اكثر من
سنه ولكنها
فتحت تحقيقات بسرعه لاسباب اهمها ان
اربعين دوله طرف في المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تقدمت بطلبات من اجل فتح تحقيق
والدول الاطراف المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
هي بمثابه الجناح التشريعي الذي يؤثر بشكل
او باخر على اسراع الاجراءات
مقارنه باجراءات على سبيل المثال مثل
الاجراء الفلسطيني الذي استضد فتح
التحقيقات في سنوات لاسباب مختلفه
صدر القرار باصدار مذكرات التوقيف بعد شهر
من تقدم الطلب بها وليس في هذا السرعه
يعني مبالغه بالنسبه لقرارات التي تصدر عن
الدوائر القضائيه اما السرعه فهي في تحرك
مكتب الادعاء من اجل توجيه التهم في جريمه
معينه للاشخاص معينين طبعا مقارنه بملفات
اخرى وهذا يعود الى تاثير الدول الاطراف
خصوصا في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه على
السير بسرعه بملف دون غيره طيب سيد الجانب
الروسي ردا على هذا القرار عاد التفكير
بموقفه من اي تسويه
سياسيه تاثير هذا القرار على التسويه
السياسيه طالما ان الجانب الروسي يقول
بانه يجب الغاء هذا القرار باتجاه اي
تسويه سياسيه
اعتقد اننا لا نفكر الان باي تقديم اي نوع
من الاجابات لهذا القرار هذا هو جوابنا
نحن نتجاهل وهذا القرار وذا نلتفت اليه
كثيرا
ما هي ضروره
ضروره الكبيره للرئيس بوتر بان يقوم
بزياره مصالح مشتركه ستكون يكون هنالك حل
لهذه القضيه شكرا لك
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين كنت معنا من
موسكو والشكر موصول لديالا شحاده المحاميه
السابقه في محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ومن
واشنطن
مساعد الرئيس الامريكي السابق لشعور روسيا
واوكرانيا الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]